this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by coors pure
upstart ritual and liquid iv more on
that later let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler
on all social media um look i do want to
thank you guys we've been um
growing this show for a year now and um
i don't know when this will air but
we're right at about a hundred thousand
subscribers i think i don't know how to
say it i don't know if that's good
progress or not but i feel like it is so
[ __ ] everybody else we're just keeping
our head down doing our thing over here
subscribe to the youtube channel you get
audio on monday
you get the video on tuesday uh don't
just watch
subscribe um and if you gotta have more
honeydew hit up the patreon we're doing
an episode a week and we're not just
doing 30 minutes we're doing at least an
hour with everybody
um and we're hearing some wild [ __ ] i
mean wild [ __ ]
and that show is not going anywhere
anytime soon so it's five bucks a month
you now will get the honeydew video a
day early ad
free uh at no additional charge so five
bucks a month for the rest of the year
and uh if you sign up for your year you
get over a month free so
uh that community continues to grow and
blow me away
if you or someone you know has a story
that has to be heard submit it to
honeydewpodcast
gmail.com and hopefully we get to do an
episode with you
night pants nation is another thing that
continues to grow i love seeing y'all
out there in your night pants
taking those pictures snatching them up
the joggers are available now
everything is restocked get over there
get yourself some merch
and you know i record here at the santa
monica music center every week we are
working with some
kids at risk youth and the santa monica
police department on this podcast that
i've been telling you about
and when it comes out i'm gonna promote
it i'm proud of it these kids are doing
some really cool things opening up
dialogue with the police um
and it's outreach through the arts otta
we call it
here at the santa monica music center
now if you're new here
we highlight the low lights over here
it's a beautiful [ __ ] show
uh if you're not new here you know these
are the stories behind the storytellers
ladies and gentlemen
it is a pleasure to have back here on
the honeydew the man to help me start it
all
your favorite mommy y'all teddy loons
thompson gore y'all
i like the soft foods the software just
put them up there
just little lay-ups dude thank you for
being here of course ben thanks for
all this has started with you the last
time you were in this studio
yeah the day after i call you
and we're getting looted and yeah in the
middle of the [ __ ] room your crazy
ass
tells me i just i drove back just to see
what was that
i was like why well i had the gum fold
on me yeah
i had a guy come up and show me the gun
but what i found out did he say
something to you
yeah i got hate grime that he called me
a [ __ ]
i got hate crimes in the black lives
matter movement god damn it
what do you say what are you looking at
get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ]
[Laughter]
did you say something back yeah
all right i don't care what you say
about me or anybody i'm like my daughter
is a
yeah [ __ ] i pulled around the corner
he's he just ran
over with it like this he goes get the
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] and i was like
whoa bro i left i came back because
louie lotta's husband was still on the
corner he didn't see it i'm like you
they got guns dude get out it's time to
go and then the police later reviewing
the video
told lana they showed her they said look
what your friend
also doesn't know is there's a guy
behind his car with a gun so i never
even
knew that person was there saw that
person or anything so i remember i had
people at my house
and you could see you could see all this
[ __ ] from my house
you see the smoke coming up and you you
you called me
and i told my friend i was like my
friends you see that smoke yeah
my friend just drove back they go tell
them to get the [ __ ] out of there
that's what i said we stayed till the
end i mean we stayed till
till they picked up the [ __ ] and threw
it through the wind and i was like ah
we've done a roll it's time to go yeah
but we made it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah deal got honey
dude i got honey dude i did
pull around back i'm like is it is it
the hair bro i'm trying to grow my hair
out man you make me feel insecure
i haven't really grown thanks appreciate
it and that's real salt and pepper
for 63. you look great i got a great
head of hair for you you really do
i do i feel good about it yeah i'm like
we're all great now look at my beard man
it's like straight up just a minute i
know it's crazy to even think about
i know just uh promote anything you want
to promote right now do you have
anything that's going on that's timely
so we can put this up so
uh i'm doing i mean i'm doing the road
and i'm announcing dates like every
every week new stuff gets announced and
i'll have a tour announced
pretty soon uh but it's all at
tomsgrow.com
so and then ymhstudios.com has a bunch
of uh
you know we do these live shows and then
they're rentals and then
we have a whole bunch coming up it's
insane reynolds what do you mean
so like you live streaming we live
streaming the show right but then like
after
for a week live event you can just rent
it oh that's considered a rental it's
called a rental yeah yeah so
and but you leave it up for in
perpetuity yeah yeah oh it's not this
exclusive thing like well you can rent
it it gets pulled down no you can rent
it anytime you can run it anytime and
the rental i think it lasts a week okay
i see yeah and then you own it
the no like the rental exp it's like
renting a movie
on itunes or something you can rent it
and just you know watch it right i see
yeah um all right there's a lot to talk
about you guys are [ __ ] leaving which
is very upsetting to me
i know and i i'm surprised we're really
excited
i know you are you should be yeah it's
time yeah i mean you know i'm
i'm thinking about a whole bunch of
stuff you know and it's like
i'm just not that excited about la
anymore and i
i think the year let me know that like i
can do what i do
from anywhere all of us can yeah and
then i go like you know i've always
liked going to austin
and i've gone a lot lately every time i
go i really really enjoy i mean it has
it's like the perfect scene you know but
you're also
a florida guy too so like i know people
are like i don't want to
camp and fish and i'm like yeah i'll
definitely go [ __ ] fish oh yeah i got
six rods strung up right now to go to
big bear this weekend i love that
lake life is there yeah i love you know
my predominant
like thing is touring touring from the
middle of the country versus from here
is going to be a cut-out game
i get it and then uh i think it'd be
really cool to raise my boys there man
like to have that be where they really
grow up yeah
it's exciting i lived for almost a year
in texas when i was a kid
you did yeah my dad got transferred from
uh national ronald reagan now to houston
and we lived down there for about a year
and i learned i think i told christine i
learned to swim in in texas i learned to
climb trees
like i felt like i got like some boy
[ __ ] in texas oh yeah stayed with me
christina took ellis there and there's
videos of him just throwing rocks and
she's like not at houses
dude he [ __ ] breaks everything
he breaks he's seriously he's like a
little tasmanian and he'll also just
like
lay next to me and kick me like what are
you doing he's like sorry i'm like yeah
but you kicked me
why are you kicking me he's like i'm
sorry
[Laughter]
well what made you want to kick me i
don't know i don't you're there sorry
i'm getting a lot of that
attitude so i'm like what all right so
let's talk about
the story behind the dunk champ yes i
really want to know
everything that was going on it's a lot
man
um first why did you
decide to have a dunk comp you're gonna
laugh specifically you're gonna laugh at
it specifically
specifically i don't think i've actually
said this
i so i played burton tennis
and dude i don't know if you know this
but you told me this
but say it because i couldn't get over
it so i was i was playing at one point
i think we played ten i forget when we
played but i ended up
i played a lot as a kid for a couple
years i was never
exceptional but i was decent you know
could play
and when we talked to him you know sport
sports like tennis
if if i go did you play tennis you know
i played as a kid i don't know what that
means
i don't know if you you know like were
you a competition level person or
so we play tennis and i
as i'm getting closer to the match i'm
playing three times a week
and is this just for exercise at the
time or well like no once we decide
we're going to play tennis is just a bet
too or is this you two are just gonna
no we're challenging each other we're
gonna shoot it for content and like put
it on one of our live shows and
and we always talk [ __ ] to each other i
bet i can beat you at this and you know
so as we're getting closer to it my
you know my coach is like you know your
[ __ ]
ground game is like pretty legit right
now like your forehand is
is really really really good and he's
like you know
as long as you can serve and receive his
serve like you're going to [ __ ] him up
unless unless he's like really good so
we go that day tonight
look i hear you and that body does not
scream lateral
movements no man and when i see him when
i see him hitting
the forehand and back it i was like oh i
i'm going to
kill him you know and we we go we rally
a little bit like to warm up
and then he starts serving and i'm like
what is happening
like what bert mcenroe he is serving
and he has different serves kickback
serves putting spin on the server
so that's this whole game is to serve
but so if you can return it you gotta
but if you can't you're [ __ ]
and i and by the way when we're training
for it like when it's really getting
close to it i go you know let's work on
serve returns he's like mike my coach
who was a big time d1 tennis player
he starts he goes he's not going to
serve like this dude like he's not gonna
serve like me
you know i go yeah of course not well he
served i look at him one time during the
match and he's like
what did he say it's a what well after
after it like burt just
absolutely kicked the [ __ ] out of him
that's the way you score you don't get
one of them returned i mean maybe one
out of like 30.
oh yeah just and i'm demoralized i mean
i'm like
so is he just talking [ __ ] everything
else too no
no he's not i but i just can't believe
and i win the first
two games so it's i'm up 2-0 to start
i'm like oh that's all right
how'd you win those he he
he's not i'm serving poorly so the few
times that i'm serving okay he's
i don't even think he's returning them
any time like we can start a rally
i'm basically winning but he starts
serving and i'm like
and i'm just the thing is it's one of
those things where it like snowballs
like
i start to just get down i'm like [ __ ]
it's over
when it's over you just kill he wins
like six two six one just kills me
and i'm just like so depressed about it
and i i walk over the coach he goes i
gotta tell you something when i go what
he goes that's a legit d1 college surf
and i go what the [ __ ] bert what was
that he goes i told you i used to play i
go what the [ __ ] did you play man
did you play international games and
then the funny thing is my coach goes
i've never seen
such a disparity between someone serving
their ground game
it's like he just worked on one thing
but one thing i've
learned over time about burke because
burt will always tell you what a great
athlete he is
he'll tell you like i'm one of the is
that you know there's different types of
athleticism
right like i'm used to when someone says
they're an athlete
for like what i grew up doing and
playing
athlete means run the fastest jump the
highest
like raw like football player like
combine [ __ ]
yeah like that's the great athlete so i
was like what are you talking about but
what he does legitimately have
legitimately is incredible hand-eye
coordination
like it's definitely above average
hitting a baseball
hitting a golf ball tennis serve bow and
arrow all that [ __ ] like it's impressive
he did that bow and arrow thing on the
go big show bullseye and they were all
like
what like he really is good at that and
if you i've seen him hit a golf ball i'm
like
like impressive really good at it so he
beat the [ __ ] out of me at that
and he goes what's the what are we gonna
do next so i go i know
like without a doubt that i'll [ __ ] him
up in basketball
like not talking about dunking just one
on one i played
so much basketball even though i haven't
played in a while i'm like i know he
didn't play basketball so i'm like i
just want to pick something
that i'll definitely beat him in that's
even better yeah
because it's all ego driven so i go
we'll do basketball he ends up reaching
out to tristan jass who's like this
youtube kid
really talented really good guy too and
so he's he's like you know let's do this
thing with tristan agrees
so the whole idea is we're going to play
two on one versus tristan
then we're going to play one on one
versus each other then we're gonna do
the dunk contest it was just to have
something else to do who came up with a
dung competition
i don't remember if i suggested it or
not i just knew that like
when we talked about it it was it was
like oh yeah that makes sense
we'll lower it and then whoever can do
it higher i mean
never thinking that anything would go
wrong
yeah so we played two on one and tristan
beats us
he's one versus two in basketball his
points count as one ours count as two
how bad did he beat you by one and bert
missed an open layup
to to win the game that's that ground
game man yeah i told him
i could shoot three i'm gonna hate you
for a whole day for from [ __ ] that up
he's like let's don't talk about it
okay so when he when we finish
two-on-one
i think i go let's just play one-on-one
now but then lindsay
who works with us goes why don't we go
to the other end they've lured the hoop
already we can do that
then we'll play one-on-one after and i
was like well you know what our legs
will be fresher like jump now yeah so
okay that makes sense so we go down
there
and the hoop is lowered to seven and a
half feet i mean it's you know you
basically just reach up
and put it in and we start doing it that
way seven and a half eight
eight and a half nine he couldn't do
nine
i've seen your nine foot i did nine and
it's
and then they're like it's over like you
beat i was like great so that's like one
le
one part of our competition now let's go
play one on one
i mean i've said it on podcasts already
but then
i forget who it was goes i think you can
do a little bit higher and i was like
so it wasn't enough for you to win you
wanted to well it's i don't know
it wasn't even that i wasn't like i
think i could do higher somebody else
said it and i was like i remember being
like
i remember feeling the uh the adrenaline
surge of them saying if someone's saying
i think you can do this and i was like
like can i i don't know and there was
that guy roy if you watch the
the video on our on our youtube channel
who said he's a basketball coach and he
coaches people privately and
works and he he pulled me aside he was
like
you have to dig deep on this one man
yeah i was like yeah he was like
because he knew it was like the nine was
close to the limit
like but also nine and a half is that
much closer to ten it is
you know what i mean that's they put it
to nine three nine three
they raised it three inches which i was
like okay and i remember thinking i was
like
man i might be able to like i knew i
could grab the could you dunk back in
the day
no i could touch the rim i could like
like kind of like hook it okay but i
could never dunk a basketball in it
i could yeah no a five time i'd be just
split away i told you what uh what
happened to
i didn't i tell you about that kid in my
college uh
dorm hall my freshman year i don't know
the goofiest [ __ ] guy i've ever met
he had he had hair parted down the
middle that
like split here yeah
he was like hey tom he had a goofy ass
carolina accent
he came in my room and he was like i got
a big dick and i was like oh that's not
the same but
this kid's got a nine inch yeah and he
would cover 360. open his towel and like
helicopter his dick around just show
people
yeah dude we're freshmen everyone's a
jackass on the freshman hall
and one day we're just talking can you
listen i talk about this
all right like why we're so different
like yeah
why can't you and i as just two
heterosexual male friends lay in bed
together and watch a movie like girls do
what we can what do you got what are you
doing right now it's just tom and i over
here laying in bed together watching
we're just holding each other sexual
yeah just watching a movie you know
girls do this [ __ ] all the time all the
time
what chick is coming in showing you her
[ __ ] you know what i mean yeah look at
this poster
well there's a there are a few of them
there's always some
there's a few you don't want to date
them but they're fun to have around you
pay those girls yeah
that's uh yeah this dude uh what's his
name
yeah his name was justin he was just
goofy man and
he goes um i forget how the comment but
he says i can does his dick big
yeah just helicoptering it around yeah
yeah and he had
a a lean slight build but average
average built like you feel like it's
those swimmers bodies guys those
skinny like pete davidson guys yeah he's
got a hammer on him yeah yeah for sure
for sure so he's kind of like that he's
maybe like
six feet i don't know if he was six one
maybe i think he's like six feet tall
at the time i remember and then he goes
i can he said he could dunk and i go get
the [ __ ] out of here he goes no for real
and i go hold my dick
[Music]
so i'm like dude okay and i say
something to him like
let's go right now he's like okay so we
walk from the freshman dorm over to the
gym
we're at the indoor 10-foot room this is
the
gym that the college team plays on this
is the regulation
like gymnasium you know and i go you can
dunk
he walks up and does a 360. yeah did he
even play on the team right now no
no he's just like playground guys and he
was like i told you
a [ __ ] full double two hit pow and i
was like
no he was like yeah
i was like why did you get that gift you
goofy [ __ ] like
he was uh so unworthy of it but but yeah
he just did it you know
in front of me like that so anyway back
to the
to the day like i remember that dude
said that to me and i remember i do
last round
you need to come to the party man he did
tell me to come to the party
you're getting the [ __ ] big daddy
party man you need to come to
you got that speech yeah he told me he
told me that that the rim was taking my
remote control and trying to change the
tv in my [ __ ] house
so it says [ __ ] you i played that for an
nfl player yesterday
cassius march placing the steelers he
was like what is this
so oh god i told him uh i once i played
that coach i speech
for finesse mitchell who played at miami
i played with the canes
finesse played for them yeah oh i didn't
know that yeah finesse said he goes he i
played in that
that speech he goes you know what i
didn't hear in this video i go white
goes anything about football
yeah anything about football so
roy tells me like and i remember
like you know when you go like like you
you could feel that you're
too hyped up i felt like i felt it like
my heart rate was up
like dried out in the throat but i was
like well like use this
energy to go you know
i just line up and you know you've seen
the video a hundred times but like
you do your new mba logo bro what i what
i remember
is that i push off on my left foot
right because there's two there's two
foot jumpers and there's like the one i
guess i'm a one foot jumper
so i push off and i don't know what
happens like in your mind you're just
like like it you know it's fast
i felt like i didn't feel pain i just
knew that like
something happened so it's not slo-mo
right here it's just
instant like down fat i mean so fat i
mean i felt like i got
shot i was like what the [ __ ] like it
just it was so fast
and then i don't know the thing is i
don't know if i'm
two inches off the ground or 20. you
know i mean like
when you push off and you feel something
goes wrong it's
it isn't an instant so like on the push
off you feel pain
i don't feel pain nothing you just feel
yourself sort of losing control
yeah and i and i'm like oh it's like
it's like the engine died
you know i'm like and i just remember
being like like
kind of surprised what's happening in
the moment
and instinctively instinctively
like i don't think put your arm behind
you
it just goes behind me listen when you
first told me i said that you put your
head you're like no my arm went behind
me
yeah i watch football every sunday i see
that
that thing happens a hundred times a
game
and i'm just i'm just like that [ __ ]
crushed tom's arm yeah he's 20 year old
studs and
hitting her having bodies falling oh
yeah [ __ ] and i've
fallen a hundred times i mean
but it was just i think it was like your
arm so your left foot you're up in the
air
and then your left arm just falls behind
this
no no not even like that okay it's like
it just like tucks back
it's like tucks back like it's an
instinctive thing that you're doing to
basically
protect your back and head yeah you know
i mean like you're like oh like you're
you're not consciously thinking i should
put my arm behind me it just happens
and i landed on it just [ __ ] and your
body weight [ __ ] snapped it now i mean
you sent me the picture of that thing
snapped inside yourself
and it is [ __ ] it looks like a
cartoon i'm doing a podcast with the
surgeon
uh next week like he because he was like
this is a major trauma yeah that's what
i want to talk about yeah yeah
so something you now you hit the ground
yeah and what pain are you feeling the
arm just the arm just the arm i don't
think something's wrong with my leg
is it immediate it's immediate and
intense intense it's in are you do you
feel like you're gonna pass out
no i just feel like like basically this
face i'm like
you know like i can't i can't like be
alert i'm just like you're just
you're so so feeling the intensity of
that pain
and that like that's all you in that
video if you see that immediately
i go call 9-1-1 yeah right because
they're all in shock they don't know
like it also happened that fast to them
so they're all like uh you know you can
hear one of the kids one of tristan's
shooters go his arm his arm i swear i
heard roy go
quit [ __ ] around man just come on man
dig deep like yeah
yeah do you know what uh did i tell you
that
what i think it's in there i think he
can get tim
but i tell you that he uh he pulled me
aside he was like
you got that larry johnson like right
because i was when i was dunking on like
eight and a half
larry yeah i had the two-handed thing
and i go to the old
tooth stick and call it a brother in my
bag i had a larry johnson jersey
yes what are the odds yeah i brought it
for that day
i just didn't put it on never got to
wear it you still got it then
i still have it so
dude i was i was a college kid playing
with a gold tooth
that team was [ __ ] they were
something else these kids now don't if
you want to look up some [ __ ]
see some chats yeah go look at that unlv
score that was like what 91.92 yeah it
was in an early night and they
[ __ ] people up they did yeah larry
johnson who looks
like a defensive end grandma nfl but i
mean
we're talking six seven 255 and like
massive big [ __ ] guy man and him
stacy augment and those guys just
that's what i mean i remember being a
kid being like i'm gonna be this [ __ ]
team yeah these guys are the [ __ ]
yeah and then uh tark chewing those
towels and telling those kids
you don't have to go to class that's not
yeah don't worry about that yeah
it's about basketball about winning
[ __ ] games yeah let's take a quick
break and tell you about our first
sponsor
upstart if you have multiple credit
cards you know that tracking multiple
balances due dates website logins all
that stuff can be stressful
upstart makes things simple with one
monthly payment
in one place upstart is the fast and
easy way to get a personal loan to pay
off your debt
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
upstart finds smarter rates with trusted
partners because they assess more than
just your credit score with a
five-minute online rate check you can
get approved the same day and you can
receive your funds as fast as one
business day if debt is taking over your
life it's time to get a fresh start
with upstart listen i know you guys use
upstart you hit me up about it
you've gotten great rates you've gotten
uh consolidation one monthly payment i
wish i had something like upstart back
in the day
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
honeydew that's upstart.com honeydew
don't
forget to use my url to let them know i
sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
go to upstart.com honeydew our next
sponsor is liquid iv when we push our
body hard or we're just feeling run down
it's extremely important to take care of
ourselves with the proper vitamins and
nutrients that's why liquid iv
created hydration multiplier plus immune
support to maintain and strengthen
your immune system look i've told you i
took it all during coronavirus when i
actually had it
and i took the immune it really helped
me it's got the vitamin c the
zinc all of that stuff that's my
favorite one
i love it but the other flavors they
have are great too they got
watermelon strawberries a lot of good
stuff out there
now hydration multiplier plus immune
support
is a cutting-edge blend of vitamin c
zinc and well-mewn
in convenient single serving packets to
help strengthen your immune system
when you purchase liquid iv you're
joining their mission to help people
live
better lives everywhere with every
purchase liquid iv
donates a serving of liquid iv to
someone in need liquid ivy has donated
four plus million servings in response
to coven 19.
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans
and active military the company has
donated over 10 million
servings globally get your liquid ivs
hydration multiplier plus immune support
in bulk at costco or order online and
get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com and you
use my code honeydew at checkout
that's 25 off of anything you order when
you get better hydration today
using promo code honeydew at
liquidity.com
now let's get back to the do but they
were the [ __ ] anyway
i just remember i think i've uh i told
you those paramedics came
well bert takes your arm and readjusts
it yeah because it's stuck but right
it's stuck but pulls it and that's not a
good thing to do either though is it
they would make
there's a strong case there's that's not
a good thing to do they usually like
don't touch
people that are broken yes snapped in
half leave that but
then it just dropped and i was like when
he did it did it hurt when he moved it
i don't remember it was everything hurt
it hurts so intensely
but at this point you have no idea still
there i don't know what i know my arm is
broken but
i'm talking about your leg you didn't
even know that because your pain is so
intense don't feel a [ __ ] anything else
i don't feel a thing in my left wow
which they told me later is very common
when you have like that double whammy
that your brain
will process one of the pains so much
that you won't feel pain like i didn't
feel pain in my leg until like five six
days later
damn that long okay so
paramedics come this [ __ ] guy the
whole he goes what are you doing playing
with kids man
kids kids i was like what
i'm on the ground you know
i was like what are you what he's like
he's probably seen this [ __ ] enough
hey you're up there man he's like do you
[ __ ] around these kids anymore and then
they're like they're like you know
asking me questions i'm like yup
this arm yep this leg and then the guy's
like radio and he's like yeah we're
going to transport
uh and the same guy
[Music]
he did the same guy kept going he's
playing with kids
he kept saying he kept saying it we get
in the back of that do you think he was
[ __ ] 10 years older than me and he
was like he
you know we get in the back of the
ambulance she was like i don't know why
you're out there playing with kids man i
go just shut the [ __ ] up
like we get to the emergency room
and the doctor's like oh he's like yeah
he's out there playing with kids
i'm like he couldn't let it go couldn't
let it go
couldn't let it go whole time talking
about kids i'm like shut up
you know what i remember too i uh like
two and a half months before this i
remember exactly where i was
i was in oklahoma city i just got to the
hotel
i'd started like doing stand-up at the
places that had that were saying we'll
do like half capacity i was doing like
one a month so this is like the second
one i've done since the pandemic started
and i have uh josh potter with me and
we're leaving the ho i go we get we
check in
i go it's like i don't know let's say
it's like early afternoon
you want to get coffee he's like yep and
they they tell us there's a good coffee
place
around the corner so we're walking up
that street and i go did i tell you what
we're doing for the
the next challenge bert and i and he
goes what so we're gonna do
basketball and then we're gonna do this
dunk contest
and josh goes i gotta tell you man
that's how guys your age get [ __ ] up
oh you two stop i go what he goes i
don't know if you really want to do that
and i go one he goes guys in their 40s
play basketball they tear their acls
they get they tear their achilles it's i
mean i've seen it a bunch and i was like
i don't know i'm not worried about it
kept walking i just i remember it
so vividly you know him being like could
go wrong and i was like i mean i guess
it could but
i'm not really concerned so i'm in this
hospital
that i don't like to name because i
don't want to but
immediately i know that this is not a
great hospital
i know it's close to where we played
basketball i don't know it by name i'm
saying when we pull up i'm like
[ __ ] this place so they put me in the
uh you have by the way you have intense
memories
when you have like a traumatic thing
what do you mean like your father passed
away
i'm sure you remember the details of
that day vividly
right it's a traumatic event i remember
so much
so vividly i see that day of that and
especially of like
from the injury on for that month it's
like i remember people's names
so i'm in this i get in this emergency
room
and they've done like they then they're
like we gotta wrap your arm
so it's it's fresh broken and they start
giving me like fentanyl
in the ambulance i don't feel any like i
don't feel the effects of that
they're like how's your pain i'm like
it's [ __ ] 15. like what are you
talking about
then there's a [ __ ] lunatic next to
me scott and they're like stop it scott
because he's like like yelling and [ __ ]
and then you start snoring right away
yep and then he went
you're like i'm in pain and they're like
shut up scott like yelling at him
yeah and i'm like i gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here
so they start coming in and it's always
a new person are you in pain i got
yeah i'm in a lot of pain and they start
just giving me
drugs like pills and i'm like look man
whatever you're just so you know i'm not
feeling it at all
like i don't feel what you're giving me
and they're like oh okay
so they just up it you know start giving
me higher doses
and finally they go now we're going to
wrap your arm [ __ ]
so it's fresh broken oh and they wrap it
and it's like
it is killing you yeah they do x-rays
and they x-ray the leg they put a
straight brace on the leg they're like
well we know this thing's [ __ ]
and then that's the first time you're
even finding out about the leg right
there when they're like this thing's
[ __ ] too
oh yeah yeah how do they know did they
do full body like
yeah well they they they realize it like
the injury happened i go something
happened
with my i don't know what happened with
my knee but also my patella moved
so so they're like your patella is over
here well then that's why i go
yeah yeah we should probably check that
out so
dude these people come in x-ray tech
then um
they you know they give me the drugs and
then after a while they're like so like
you know
you're gonna need surgery and i was like
tonight and they're like well if you
could but i don't think there's someone
available right now
so uh who like do you have someone you
want to reach out to and i go [ __ ] yeah
so i called my physician who i've had
for
almost 15 years or something he's like
hey
but like you know casually what's up man
i go i'm in the hospital and blah blah
he's like what are you doing like
super cat one of those kids i'm like man
here's what happened he starts talking
to the uh
i go talk to the emergency room guy and
they start talking about this and that
and i go hey who's
he's always giving me great referrals if
you go like ah this is going on go see
this guy
i go who should i have do this surgery
he's like you know
like the two best people i know are out
of town right now
and i'm like okay so do you have like
another suggestion he's like i can't
really think of one
i'm like for real like yeah
i go all right men so then i i'm talking
to this doctor he goes well we have
somebody
who usually is here let me reach out to
her
and you know he go he goes away comes
back she'll see you tomorrow
and then we could have surgery like
later tomorrow or the next day
and i was like okay and in my head i'm
like i know i gotta get out of here like
i just don't trust it you know
so they set me up and i don't realize
that for the
like the last two hours they've been
giving me just opiates
and when i sit up i just open into a
full sweat like i wasn't sweating and
then i sit up
and it's like you opened a valve and i'm
like and i'm like
like i didn't realize that's what it
took me to feel [ __ ] up
and then i go i just got a man and they
put me in a wheelchair and i go
i want to go pee so you start to wheel
me to a bathroom
and the guy looks at me he goes are you
all right man like you look
really [ __ ] up and i was like i'm fine
because i didn't want them
to be able to keep me there so the guy
one of the doctors goes wait do you want
to leave and i go yes
he goes you want to leave the hospital i
go yeah and he goes
um all right i just you know i gotta
sign some things and he's like where are
you gonna go i was like i don't know
home and he was like okay i'm going to
go home with the
what i didn't realize so
i didn't realize that when they
discharged me
everybody goes you know that was a good
decision to leave that place
but you should go to another hospital
yeah and i was like i'll just go home
where nothing's gonna get fixed at all
yeah so
lindsay picks me up we go to the
the drugstore broken arm
and what are you wrapped in it's just a
face mask yeah like
with like and like cardboard it's like
the shittiest wrap you could possibly do
yeah cardboard yeah and then and the and
the legs and the straight brace and i'm
like
dude i'm so [ __ ] up it's like the
nurse's t-shirt
oh man and then i get when i get home
he backs into my garage
bert and leanne had like come over and
set things up in our basement so who's
told christina first well i think i told
her first
when did you call her in the in the back
of the ambulance you did
and what is her reaction do you remember
all that yeah she was like okay i go i'm
okay like you know i go i'm hurt
but i'm okay and i'm gonna you know i'm
on my way to the hospital and i'll let
you know what happens blah blah blah and
then i ended up texting her like i'm
coming home
dude when i get home
i mean it starts to hit me as like
they're trying to get me in the house
that i can't do
anything like they're they carry me over
the like the step to go into the house
and like they carry me down the stairs
and then they carry me and place me on
this couch in our basement and i'm like
and then bert had gone to the store and
he
he put snacks on like doritos and i'm
like what is this he's like in case you
get hungry i'm like
you i'mma eat cheetos right now
and then you know what he put right on
the stand right next to my head
calcium he's like i figured you could
[Laughter]
your use yeah i'm like what the [ __ ] man
so then uh
bird always jokes about how leanne is so
direct
like she never bites her tongue she goes
that's gonna be a problem
you're gonna be in trouble for a while
and i'm like thanks he goes shut the
[ __ ] up
she goes no i mean it's gonna be a real
problem tom
you're probably gonna gain a lot of
weight too and i was like great thanks
stop by
but they helped so much because
christina was just overwhelmed you know
she's got the kids and she's like what's
that like
so i try to go to
i can't sleep i mean i'm in excruciating
pain
and i go all i tell him is like the next
day like we had talked to a doctor
friend who goes you need to go see this
orthopedic guy the next day like at his
office
and she arranges for the for the
appointment for me i'm like okay
i tell bert you come back here and take
take me to that appointment so bert
arranges
i go arrange for like one of those
wheelchair services
like you see them paratransits yeah they
they help like
old people go to an appointment not
[ __ ] doing a dunk competition yeah
but you know he [ __ ] he finds a guy for
50 bucks
well the guy shows up he's got hair
down to his waist which is fine but you
know
it's a little like oh you work in this
field he smells like cigarettes
okay he's got a 35 year old wheelchair
like
that the legs don't even move in it it's
rusty and i'm like what the [ __ ]
why is he budgeting for this i don't
know i'm like bert he's like that's all
i could find
so this guy puts me in the chair
and then i hold on to bert i go don't
you [ __ ] leave me with this guy
cause normally i would be like leave me
alone i was like don't leave me with
this guy
puts me in the chair a couple times i
think he's gonna drop me off my driveway
which is a subterranean driveway i was
like holding i was like holding on to
bert
with everything i was like [ __ ] do
not leave my side right now
so we get in there and uh the guy locks
me into the shittiest fan
that i've ever seen like it's it's just
a it's a [ __ ] box and a [ __ ] chair the
whole thing sucks
and i'm sitting there and then the guy's
like what do you do we're comedians
and the guy's like no [ __ ] like starts
turning around talking to us
he's like yeah you have netflix and the
guy's like what's netflix oh my god damn
it dude
what's next you guys totally checked out
okay
we have to give him such explicit
directions i'm like have you ever driven
anyone
in this thing before like you don't know
where anything is
so we pull up to this in in beverly
hills
there's like that whole medical district
you know so users in that area
in that area we pull up to this building
and i go and i wheel
in they wheel me in to this office
and when i walk when i plan it the
doctor walks in and he goes what are you
doing here
and i go i thought we had an appointment
he goes no no why are you not at a
hospital
and i go i left that hospital he goes i
know why aren't you at another hospital
you shouldn't be out
and i go oh yeah i went home he's like
you went home i can't believe you
at home and i'm like yeah he goes all
right
first of all you're super lucky and i'm
like what
and he goes he goes oh yeah like he goes
this [ __ ]
sucks but it's all fixable he's like you
could have hit your head
and you'd be talking with a slur for the
rest of your life he just says that like
straight to me and i was like do you
know leanne i'm like yeah
[Laughter]
so right away i'm like okay and he goes
he points to my arm he's like this is
not gonna be this would be easy fix he's
like
this knee he's like that's the that's
the real work
like of the surgery and i go okay and
he's gonna do both
no he goes he goes i could do this he
goes but like the best
trauma surgeon in this area is dr little
and i go can we get him he goes well i
can reach out to him i don't know if
he's available i don't know if he's
around i haven't talked to him today
i was like oh please reach out to him so
he's like all right i'm texting him
right now
and he goes uh get in that van
and go to cedars right now like right
now man and he goes it's gonna suck
in the waiting room you know you're
gonna be frustrated but
that's where you need to be you really
need to be there like immediately
and i go okay okay so they put me back
in the van is there any risk of
permanent damage if you don't get this
done
right away yeah like of course i mean
within days like is there a blood clot
well
all that all that is a is a concern i
mean
blood clots um have the thing is that
these are
they're considered major trauma
surgeries right
like the the major trauma injuries and
they require like a pretty sophisticated
orthopedist do you ever show the fans
the snapped clean snap
bone yeah it's been i mean it's been on
the podcast on my instagram yeah
so when um when we get in the van
[Music]
the same guy with the [ __ ] hair i'm
like
all right man just go to cedars and he
goes what's that nah and i go
[ __ ] cedar sinai the biggest hospital
in los angeles he goes where is it
it's [ __ ] around the corner it's that
building
it says cedar yeah he's like oh okay how
do i get there i'm like oh my god i'm
like what do you normally do bro
so we get we get closer he
i have to tell him not to turn down he's
like let's go over here i'm like no
emergency room's here that's where i
want you to take me
doesn't know where to go whatever we
finally get there i consider it a relief
that we actually pull up and i can get
out
and then we we get through the check-in
process
luckily so fast and then
we're in that fast track and the it's
like this
holding area before you get a room and
it's for like orthopedic injuries and
like but you
still don't know if this guy can take
you this surgeon's gonna i still don't
know
but so you're even though even though he
may or may not be able to they're like
still you need to get you need to go to
the hospital care
yeah you need care right now and he's
like you need surgery like within the
next day or so you know
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor ritual
we deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies and why especially when it
comes to something we take every day
rituals clean vegan-friendly
multivitamin is formulated with high
quality nutrients and bioavailable forms
your body can actually see
i take ritual daily vitamin daily
i take it every day it's got a great
mint i can actually taste the mint
freshness in it even though my taste is
still off and i feel way better i've
been looking for a multivitamin for a
while talk to my friends about them and
like they're telling me
we say sawdust all these other weird
things are in it i'm like where do we
get one then along comes ritual boom
ritual is the multivitamin reimagined a
multivitamin should contain key
nutrients and forms your body can
actually use to help fill gaps in the
diet no shady extras
rituals delayed release capsule design
delivers high quality nutrients
including vitamin d3 and just two daily
pills
ritual makes healthy habits easy your
multivitamins are delivered to your door
every month with free shipping
always you can start snooze or cancel
your subscription
anytime and if you don't love ritual
within your first month
they'll refund your first order get key
nutrients without the bs
rituals offering my listeners 10 off
during your first three months so here's
what you got to do visit ritual.com
honeydew to start your ritual today our
next sponsor is coors pure
do you ever feel the pressure to keep up
a healthy life
like you try to get a workout daily you
eat healthy 100 of the time
you keep up with the wellness trends you
feel like you're trying so hard all the
time and sometimes
the simple act of using a standing desk
or getting a quick run in
is enough to celebrate well let me tell
you something
celebrate those everyday triumphs with
coors pure i celebrate i come in here i
sit down ash and i record
we do our ads we do our patreons we do
the episodes
i go outside i don't have a ticket i go
home i have a course pure it's a 70
ticket here in santa monica it's
expensive and they're cleaning these
streets
all the time doesn't look like it though
coors pure is all about promoting
balance and giving aggressive
affirmations to everyday heroes coors
pure is the perfect beer
to celebrate the winds of everyday life
so when you want to enjoy a beer without
the guilt
reach for coors pure it's organic but
chill about it go to coorspure.com
to see where you can find coors pure
celebrate responsibly coors brewing
company albany georgia look
you can find them everywhere they're
hard to find sometimes in the liquor
store because everybody's snatching them
up but i found them at target
go get your cores pure at target now
let's get back to the duke
so i'm like all right man so i get in i
get in and now i'm in a bed
i'm not in my room but i'm in like this
kind of they call it the fast track so
it's like at least you're getting
processed you're you know
your name and everything and they know
that they'll kind of evaluate you
and send you somewhere from there so i i
get into that
and i have you know bert sitting here
with me he is also
this is like so not his thing
like he's he's totally like covered
paranoid like he just wanted somebody
that was like that the whole time yeah
and i could see it in his eyes you know
but he's like staying with me to make
sure i'm okay
so then i you know i end up feeling like
just it's weird but i end up feeling
like tremendous gratitude which is like
before anything happens like before any
surgery or anything i'm like i'm so
lucky to have this but also you're
you got this [ __ ] covered you know
nightmare going on in our city at that
time oh yeah and now you're having to go
into a hospital where kova people
are dude when we're going through the
emergency room to get
like checked in this guy comes in
no mask and he starts telling he's like
i have fever i'm having trouble
breathing and they're like put a mask on
like and bert you see burnt burst i
don't know why you're freaking out
totally freaked out so
when they finally start going they said
oh they sending this orthopedic team
comes in
not the the main guy but like the team
and they're like ah we looked at the
x-rays they're like yes
this is pretty bad and you know we're
gonna fix you like don't you know don't
worry it's okay like we'll take care of
you i'm like okay okay i just started
like
how's your pain i'm like [ __ ] through
the roof and he's like i got to tell you
something i go what he goes we got to
re-wrap this arm this is the worst rap
i've ever seen okay do
and i was like cool and then i tell him
i tell this first guy i go yeah i got
he's like who did this
i tell him this hospital and he goes
wait why are you here i go because i
left that hospital he goes that's one of
the smartest things you've ever done
and i don't even know you wow really
yeah
and i gotta know the one you were in i
go yeah man so
he unwraps the arm now it's just
it's broken god and i i'm in full pain
and they got to reset it and re-wrap it
they had to set it again and then he's
like hey bert give me a hand
yeah bird already gave you yeah so
bert's like helping him wrap it
hold his arm here i'm like so i re-wrap
it
uh burt gave me his earbuds i remember
that that was really nice that was nice
yeah i remember that he was like you
could have he's like do you want my
charger i was like [ __ ] yeah i want your
charger
gave me his charger and then eventually
he leaves like i tell him like i'm good
now man i'm settled here and i feel
safe but wait when have they told you
specifically
what is wrong with you yet no i don't
know i don't know exactly what's wrong
with it yet
i just know that like you're gonna have
operations you're gonna have you're
gonna have at least two operations
and i go okay so then there's these
nurses come in
and they go like you know every time
they're like how's your pain i'm like
it's [ __ ]
so it's so intense and they've given me
pills to give me this and they're like
all right we're going to go this is the
max
the max that we can give you is dilaudid
and this
doesn't happen for like a couple hours
i'm still like every time i
you know if i go like this you feel just
excruciating pain
so i'm like okay so remember the guy
comes in he goes
now this a lot of people say
that you'll feel a warm rush through
your chest so i'm just letting you know
and i go he goes that's normal and that
you know this is the most we can do here
like
there's nothing else after this i go
okay
oh and my bad bert's still there because
i remember he was still there because
they they give it to me and it was like
a clock
it was like five four because i don't
feel anything
and all of a sudden like a warm and i
was like
i was like you can go now bert
looks like you can leave i've watched a
lot of hit two people and
instantly just watch them go yeah
it was such and here's the thing the arm
still hurt but it was the first time
where i was like
well at least i think i can rest next i
don't think i'd slept in i don't know
a day and a half now or something right
i'm like
so then they're like people are coming
in
like different person every time nurse
shift changes
different doctors orthopedic team
and when is surgery the next morning no
so then they're like
you need to get x-rays so they would
wheel me out go get x-rays
wheel me back to that room hour goes by
you need more x-rays
wheel me out get x-rays go back okay
we need to do mris wheel me down get the
mri
wheel you back the whole time they're
like hey you your your room's almost
ready
like upstairs like where you have your
own proper room
okay that's like let's say four in the
afternoon five
six seven eight i'm like what's up with
the room they're like yeah yeah it's
getting ready i'm like you said like
five hours ago man
it just keeps going finally after all
the x-rays all the things
your room's ready all right they wheel
me up
now they put me in a gown and then uh
they go tomorrow morning the
the orthopedic team will come in because
now it's like 10 11 at night or
something
orthopedic team will come in give you
the full evaluation that you know what's
happening and what you're gonna do
i go okay so the next morning that
doctor dr little
shows up and i'm like you're the [ __ ]
guy i was like like so excited i was
like you're the guy
and he was like yeah man he he looks
like he's like 30. i was like
i go i thought it would be like an old
man he's like no
and he's like here's what happened you
know um he's like this is pretty bad
uh this is on your you know tells me you
tore your patellar tendon so i'm gonna
reattach that
and then i'm gonna put um he told me he
gives you an option
we can cast you up and just let
the arm break kind of heal that way like
the way you kind of remember kids
you know when you're a kid having the
broken arm he goes but
i would do the plates like that's a much
more surefire way of it
working because the cast could be like
eight weeks down the line we're like oh
it didn't
heal right and then we do surgery so
he's like you know what's up
i was like [ __ ] cut me open man do it
so that's um i have that surgery on a
friday
and i remember coming out of it being
like oh my god and seeing this crazy
scar
and then that's like the next days when
my legs started to hurt i was like oh
[ __ ]
my leg really hurts and they're like
yeah you tore your patellar tendon and
then we operated on it
like oh yeah sorry so that you told me
that thing was clean off clean up and
and he the doctor goes first when he the
first thing he told me he goes you know
it takes a tremendous
amount of force to do this i was like
yeah i was dunking
he was like what
yeah just to look at your height yeah
everything about you is
like screaming a guy that should be out
there he's like you were dunking
i was like yeah bro i've wanted the
contest
you should have asked him listen i do
you think with the force that i pushed
off i could have dunked on 9-3
i mean you know what i told him i go i
have it on video
he goes i would love to see that
he goes i i would love to see it to show
like my orthopedic
team yeah because he goes it's rare that
we have just followed injuries
an injury like this and actually be able
to see
like the results how it happened and i
go okay
so like a day later i i have lindsey i
go send me the footage you have
right he sends it to me i show it to
this guy
in my hospital but he goes ugh he's a
dog
he goes i don't want to see that again i
thought you wanted it he goes nah not
anymore
i go are you serious he goes that's
horrible i'm like
you operate on me like you up you cut
people up and he was like that was
gruesome that's like a homicide at the
time yeah going oh
jeez i don't want to work that game no
no that's nasty that's disgusting
i was like okay man so
i that's a friday on a monday i go
they put me in another ambulance and
they take me to a recovery center
because basically they go
you know if you go home right now you
have fresh
two fresh operations you're literally
incapable of doing i mean you're
left-handed your left arm is shot
and your left leg your leg is shot you
can't stand you can't
take care of yourself you can't eat you
can't go to the bathroom by like you are
incapacitated like it's it's really this
thing where you're like oh my god i'm
like disabled
right now they're like yeah you are
right now you're like give you a
handicap placard
no you could probably file for one i
probably could
but i don't give a jinx you anyway man
they get they
they uh they go they give me options of
like you can go recover at this place
that place and then
they're like and then we'll start with
uh pt and ot
at the recovery center to start
basically rehabbing you
all this like is hitting you you're like
what the like because you just feel like
all that kind of time frame for this
stuff like how long you're going to be
in the recovery center
that they're like at least a few weeks
and then they yeah and then they start
talking about like what does it take
what does it take to like come back from
these things they're like well
you're going to be in a straight brace
on your leg for six weeks so your legs
not going to bend for six weeks
and then you'll start kind of working it
back where they're like the muscle
definitely atrophy and and you'll have
to rehab that and then this arm they're
like
don't worry about the brake the brake
will just heal
but you also bruise your radial nerve so
like that controls
extenders and everything and i'm like
how long does that take and he's like
i've seen it as little as four months
and as long as like 18 months i'm like
how's it now i mean i can't like it's
much better
it's but it's much better than it was
yeah like every month it's better
but it i mean when i first was there
like i had wrist drop
which means like you can't even pull
your wrist up you know
you couldn't even do it no not at all i
couldn't i couldn't do this
are you freaking out mentally when
you're laying there at night and
nobody's around
if any of this shit's not are you gonna
have a permanent limp or are you gonna
[ __ ] have a hook
i didn't really have my grandfather they
called him hook he had broke his arm and
then
whatever didn't set right over he's
always had a he could never straighten
it all the way it was always like this
i i they made me feel like don't you
know this stuff you'll all
rehab and i believed them i was like
okay really and they're like yeah you
know
the thing they emphasize to you is like
it takes time though it's not like
a week man like it's gonna take a while
but you'll
you will be fine young kids at home you
got a lot going on
so then the next the next day um
well i get to that hot i get to the
recovery center and
they had stopped like on the day before
at the hospital doing dilaudid
they moved just to oxies to pills
i get to that recovery center i get in
bed
like they you know the paramedics put
you in a new bed
i'm kind of getting my bearings and then
the uh
nurse comes in with a needle and she
goes all right i'm gonna give you some
dilaud and i oh no
i they stopped giving to me yesterday
and she goes well you're getting it
tonight i just
put it in my arm and i was like i just
passed out like i don't remember just
went to bed
next morning i wake up and then i'm like
it starts to hit me like
oh man i i i didn't realize
how little i was capable of doing you
know at the time
i can't do and like i still i still
remember i was always
either one degree or two or two too hot
or too cold
but i couldn't control it so i have to
call someone could you
could you raise it at a degree
and they're like sure and they they're
like yeah and then like 10 minutes later
you're like could you lower it at one
degree
you have to call them in to do it it
starts to like [ __ ] with your head
that you're like i have to have someone
do that like uh that water bottle is
out of reach call someone in can you
pass me the thing that's [ __ ]
eight inches away you know that kind of
stuff yeah
and then you know so at first this whole
thing i felt was like
emotionally i felt like this
overwhelming gratitude
just that like i was taken care of that
i was able to get this amazing surgeon i
was like oh man like
you know i was told that this was the
guy and i actually got him
and i was i kept going like i'm so lucky
like in my head i'm just thinking this
i'm so lucky i have the friends i have
the family i have
i'm so lucky that i'm here and they're
taking care of me i feel really lucky
and then i feel like just depressed to
be sitting in that room
alone and i i said before like i
you don't get you don't have true
isolation but you kind of have partial
isolation
you start going like oh man what's it
like for people in real isolation
because i'm not having that much contact
i mean christina's out she's got to take
care of the kids and there's
you know she's got to keep things going
and you're not allowed to like
come for that long anyway to these
places so
i'm just sitting there like man just
kind of bummed out but like
not not super [ __ ] up about it but you
know
kind of thinking about things oh man my
life and all this and then
then the pt comes and she's like
man she told me later she's like that
first day she goes i didn't know what
the [ __ ] to do with you
why she hadn't seen anything like that
she was just like they were such
major injuries and you you were just
like laying there
i didn't think you were you were capable
of doing anything she was worried about
blood clots and infections and all this
stuff so she was like having me do ankle
pumps
just in bed like that was like she's
like just do that like move your feet
like this
i was like okay after a couple days she
goes uh hey you felt like um
she's she's coming like three days a
week to start she was have you felt like
really down like real bluesy
cried or something and i'm like no cause
i hadn't experienced
that and she goes don't worry it's
coming
and i go what she goes let's come and i
i figure it's like
the blanket thing that somebody says to
everybody
and it applies to a percentage sort of
like someone's saying don't play
basketball in your 40s you'll get [ __ ]
up
you know so i'm like exactly like that
so it's a it's friday that's when she
says it to me it's on a friday
the weekend comes saturday sunday monday
she comes for the next session
she goes uh so how you feeling like i'm
all right
she goes you feel real sad yet
i don't know because you haven't like
broken down
or anything i go no she goes it's coming
she's saying it's gone i'm like okay
like i really haven't
like it's like i i felt the gratitude
and stuff
dude she left at like
two o'clock i think like
six o'clock that night i was like like
bawling what's what started it
uh they switched my nurse on me
i didn't realize it i cried like crazy
and then
then i cried so the next morning i was
like i want them to switch my
staff to where it was and i figure what
i'll do is i'll talk to
[Music]
the person in charge but like in a very
professional manner and be like i you
know like like
going to like my like almost corporate
speech like i appreciate that you have a
way of doing things here
i just want you to know like this is
like i'm rehearsing in my head
i want you to know that um i think the
whole staff is great
but i really like the staff that i
worked with last week so if you don't
mind i would like
if it's possible just what she gets on
the phone you say what you want to talk
about
started crying like crying she's like
it's okay
i was like bawling i want my nurse yeah
i want my nurse back crying into kleenex
like
like that emotional super emotional
crying
so then she's like okay we'll switch
everything back so they switch the whole
step ass that's better thanks
and then that would happen randomly when
did that lady come in and finally ask
you if you did broke
oh yeah well she came on wednesday she's
like hey dude i go yeah i've been crying
a lot
she's like i told you yeah she's like i
told you tell him you've requested her
back
well she's my pt she's my pt oh yeah so
that's dr karen jubera she's fantastic
so she knew that [ __ ] was coming
huh and you know it was funny do you
know chris distefano yeah so
chris used to be a pt
so he he reached out to me when i first
got in and i didn't see him for a while
when i saw him next and he doesn't know
any of this stuff
he goes uh he was like yeah did you uh
did you get like real emotional
at one point and i was like yeah he goes
did you feel like really connected to
people that were like caretaking for you
i was like yeah
he's like did you feel like parts of
your personality almost like
shifted and stuff like yeah he goes yeah
that's what we see like
all the pts see it the doctors and
nurses don't really
prepare you for that part of it but the
pt's all know
why do they know you're gonna cry what
is it to hit you they they
according overwhelming gratitude or they
according to that like
chris explained it in a really
interesting way like
yes part of it is that so the way that
he explained it
is that when you get a a big injury like
i had a severe injury your brain
is like this is super traumatic but
we have to deal with the physical part
of this
like the fact that things are broken and
you you need to get into recovery
so you kind of compartmentalize the
the trauma emotions and you you kind of
store them for a minute
and then as you are coming out of like
now like they repair you like you're
coming out of surgery
then your brain goes well we don't have
to like we can
relieve some of this expression because
you're somewhat put together so then it
just starts to come out because we saw
it like
almost every time we worked with
somebody that had like he said that like
people he would see like real
personality shifts in people like some
people like
they're completely different afterwards
and stay that way yeah he's like it's
like they come out of their shell
totally different i i mean i don't feel
like that degree of change
but i do feel different emotionally you
do and personality wise yeah yeah i mean
i've said it like on
other podcasts where like i go i'm i'm
way more social like in the last few
months meaning
just like reaching out to people more
checking on people
meeting new people and being like yeah
like like things i would never
have done a few months ago like hanging
out with people that like
i feel like i operated like on a a
bandwidth of like this is my these are
my this is my family
these are my friends everybody else i'm
cordial and polite to
but i don't look to take it any you know
what i mean
any further than that and now i feel
like i'm seeking like
more connections and stuff i mean it
actually it's in my head all the time
that's your next album right there bro
see you in connection seeking
connections
or like just don't play ball against
champ yeah yeah
dunk champ but it it was like it was
like an emotional experience that i did
not expect to happen
well so much came because i wanted to
come visit you and you're like well you
got to get a corona test yeah i'm like i
just had one a few days ago you're like
no you gotta get one within like
48 hours they had rules and then i got
covered
well that's the only reason i found out
i had covet i had just got tested i
would have never
in under normal circumstances gotten
another test a few days later
yeah if i just tested negative but i had
to to come see you
and then i get the results over the
weekend i'm like there's no way this
shit's positive
and then everybody on my side has got it
i was so sick in there but you didn't
have it when i had it right i called you
and you got it right after i told you i
had it right so my second week
on my second week in that recovery place
on a tuesday
on a tuesday they came they came and
they did i did back-to-back pt and ot
back-to-back like an hour of each and
these are people coming in from the
outside
yes right and they come in i do it and
as the ladies leaving the pt's leaving
i put my head back and i sleep for like
three and a half hours
i wake up i'm like man i'm so tired so
tired not thinking anything
like related to a sickness i'm just like
oh this is like
fatigue because i'm weak and i'm doing
like
this physical therapy
the rest that day i'm like man i'm beat
go to bed
next day i wake up i'm like [ __ ] i'm so
tired
i remember my neck and my shoulders just
ached like crazy
and i ate like a regular breakfast and i
had diet like
horrible diarrhea and then i i was
supposed to do another like pt session
she was like just rest but everyone
thinks you're just tired right
from the work you're doing i must have
taken like a five hour
nap that day or something man it was
like i was so wiped out
and i just keep going the bathroom and
i'm like [ __ ] i'm so beat up
and then the next day it's like a little
bit better
you know i still don't feel great and
then friday
i'm like i'm starting to feel better
well by like when
wednesday thursday they seem they're
like you they're like we think you have
a bug no one says cove they think of a
bug
so just no more visitors so they cut off
visitors for me
like okay on friday they go do you want
to get a covet test
just to rule it out like all right
i get a test and then
i the whoever it was an outside source
that tested us
they didn't turn in the sample in time
so you leave so i leave
i finally go home on a saturday i get
home i go to sit on our
couch to watch a movie and i get oh by
the way i get all emotional seeing my
kids
like i came back from war or something i
was like my son
like yeah he's kicking me he's like
where you been man i'm like i'm [ __ ]
oh my god i had to protect myself i'll
bet you around them
so much around them i was terrified of
them because they're
two and five i mean they don't give a
[ __ ] no they throw [ __ ] at me yeah
like [ __ ] metal cars and you're like
wow
like they [ __ ] you up so
christina had hired a like part-time
nurse
to come in and care she was like i gotta
take care of the kids i can't be taking
care of you and the kids so
the nurse will be here for you for this
like first week while you get adjusted
for like
the some daytime hours all right cool
like we finished the movie and as the
movie ends i just open my phone i see
email
blah blah click the link corona test
positive
i'm like nah and then they follow with a
call they're like hey we just uh
following like it says positive like i
said like are you sure about that and
they're like yeah
yeah you have it i'm like oh my god
i'm feeling better like much better so
i'm like oh i think i
it's actually good to find out
afterwards because if you told me during
i might have been like nervous about it
right
so i'm like i actually feel fine now but
i have to tell everyone so i tell
christina i tell
you you got to tell the recovery center
all those people in there they've been
around you oh yeah they've all been
around me
so i do i um i tell christina first she
tells the nurse that it was coming to
take care of me that nurse was like i
gotta go
out i'm out so i was like all right so
she leaves and christina's like [ __ ]
now i gotta take care of you too i'm
like sorry
so then i call that recovery place and i
tell them
and that lady's like oh [ __ ] like she's
so like oh no i'm like yeah i mean it's
just what happened you know
and then i spend uh god like
a full week in the basement
you know just and i get tested again i
think i test positive one more time
then i have another someone come and
test me and i finally test negative
then christina tests positive yeah um
she has like
that cockroach dna though where like
nothing happened
i mean she was like kinda not feeling
great for like two days
none of the symptoms i had so
yeah then i finally i think i go
upstairs
for the first time december 20
you climb up the stairs yourself yeah
but like with like a peg leg
because it's still in the straight brace
dude he gave me
my doctor gave me clearance to drive i
don't believe when you were driving
january 6 with the straight brace
so like your leg your left leg is
completely straight out
but it made me feel normal to drive yeah
so yeah i mean i spent christmas up
you know upstairs and around and then
well when i came over i saw your little
old man stool that you had to sit on in
the shower that thing by the way
the most terrifying thing the whole time
was showering when i was in recovery did
you sit you just
sat and slid in bro recovery they go
there i'm
like in the hospital they do sponge bath
recovery they do sponge bath by the
second week they go do you want to
shower and i was like
no just keep doing the because
that was actually like a fear of like
you start looking at i just talked to
joey diaz because he had knee
replacement
the way you look at floors after
something happened to your knee you're
just like the thing you look for the
most is like a slippery spot yeah you
look for a water spot wet tile and [ __ ]
or
i started uh downs i used to when i get
home i always take my shoes off
and i walk around in socks in my house
but i have hardwood floors
all you need is like a little slip and
dude the adrenaline that you feel of
like oh my god something's gonna happen
to my legs so now i
take socks off i have hardwood floors
but i wear my flops i wear my adidas
yeah i mean i i just was like in a full
full panic about that but um oh so that
when i get home
so i haven't had a proper shower now in
like
weeks weeks um so i sit in this thing
but
you have to sit in the chair first take
off the brace
take off the wrap then shower
seated and like it's not the most stable
chair to begin with right you're on
scene you're like oh my god
clean yourself turn the water off dry
off
seated re-wrap re-brace
that that to me was like one of the most
stressful
periods to be in of just like i just
wanted to get out of this
and feel safe what is it like when
you're seeing your scars
um they don't really bot there's things
that like just you go i mean
the knee one is that the first time it's
not the first time you saw the scar
though right
no you would see it when they'd wrap it
and you see when they wrap it and like
it didn't really bother me the the arm
one's dramatic but like you know
everyone
at first they're like are you gonna get
a huge tattoo to cover it i was like
yeah
and then they're like what are you gonna
i'm like no i'm not actually that's a
tattoo yeah
yeah you know i just you know it's just
a scar i don't know it doesn't bother me
i mean but i dude the the showering was
full [ __ ] panic and being able to
shower
without help was like such a victory
like when i finally could be like i
don't need you to drive me off
would you say it all through this your
most vulnerable
what was was it when you broke down
about your staff being
replaced or was it feeling like taking a
shot what about wiping your ass i bought
you that wipe in the ass thing
i didn't we didn't talk about that did
you even try it i remember
listen there's no way that thing works i
kept looking at this i didn't try it
it's a gripper and you're supposed to
put it up underneath you so you can wipe
your ass like this but all it does is it
looks like it smears the [ __ ] just
everywhere there's no way dude my toilet
paper in there
my shits were well you're probably not
[ __ ] much from all the pain meds
they were giving you for a little while
first first time was five
days yeah so on day five they go have
you gone and i go no
and they go you could do a suppository
today
or we can wait but you know if you end
up
building it more it could be a problem
and i as soon as i heard that like
could get bad i was like do it today
let's do it today
yeah five days is a long time yeah i
think they do it for annie
they do it in the hospital yeah like on
the fifth day
and um i'm concerned because i've had
surgery and i go
i can't wipe like i can't you can't lean
you can't turn you can't reach
it's fresh scars you know like fresh
operations and i don't i've
really thought about it like i wipe with
my dominant hand i don't know if i could
get myself
completely clean with my but i've always
wiped with my right hand i'll have you
yeah all right i do a number of things
i do my phone everything's left-handed
but that's about i write with my left
hand
i eat like with a fork with my left hand
i brush my teeth with my left hand
but i wipe my ass and i jerk off my
right hand do you really jerk with your
right yeah i don't think i could
yeah and i throw a ball i throw a ball
with the right hand no i don't
i couldn't do that either so i remember
i was like i think i'm gonna [ __ ] and
the doctor was like that's good
because you haven't you know i go yeah
but i can't wipe he's like oh
one of the nurses will do it i was like
oh
and a nurse came in and handed me wipes
i wear these for he goes because you're
going to go to the bathroom i go yeah
but
you're going to do it and he was like
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah he like he didn't hide it at all he
was like man
he left like what are you doing he goes
i'll come back and then he
he you know he came back he did a
horrible job
wiping your ass yeah he did no what do
you mean he was just like
like it's just pat yeah he was like god
i'm dabbing it
there's so much i was like yep
and then there was another late so
he did a bad job he did a bad he didn't
want to do it he didn't think i'll do a
bad job they won't ask me to do it again
one of those like when you're a kid and
they're like do the dishes and you're
like
everything's [ __ ] dirty like i tried
yeah i did the best i could
so he did a horrible job and then the uh
the next nurse would was really like
compassionate
and and like but she would comment the
whole time
she was like gosh you got so much back
here
uh hold on oh there's some in this crack
here i was like how many cracks
was like what oh there's a crevice here
oh i didn't realize it got it spread
around hold on and she was like
like i learned some leftover [ __ ] from
dude i'm holding onto a walker
this is the [ __ ] best and then i
finally
i remember that a nurse came in who i
was like i got it
that was the was like day i had
i couldn't shoot in recovery either
because i'm still on drugs so i had to
keep doing suppositories
and then i would just unleash and then a
nurse came in to
to wipe my ass and i was like i got it
she was like really i got yeah
i got it she was like i think that's a
compliment thanks and walked away and i
was like
all right and that was like and it was
like paint but i was like oh i can do it
i can do it
[ __ ] was absolutely terrible though
terrible just to like not be able to
like you're like how many days you start
counting the days having [ __ ] in four
days
just trying to get those oxies out of
your system so that you go
normally again it was terrible so what's
the first thing
that made you feel normal um when you
healed up about driving probably yeah
driving really helped
but what's the fir what's the first
thing you did that you couldn't do
before
like pick up the kids you know i mean
well you couldn't pick them up right
obviously no no definitely not you
couldn't even if
you couldn't put weight on that knee oh
no i mean i i like at first was like
i had like strict like do not don't let
them run in here i was scared
to be asleep on the bed and have because
they'll just jump yeah right now
and there's two of them so like you know
you got to watch out like
when you're distracted by one the other
one's like i'm not dug them behind
one show and they're always like jumping
on my head and [ __ ] you know
so yeah i was i would say like
the driving the time that i when i
realized i could shower
unassisted oh my god that felt
so amazing when i got the straight brace
off
it was terrifying and i see the muscle
is completely like silly like that yeah
you see this big right quad like you can
see it you see the muscle in it it's
like thick
and then you see this left leg and
there's it's just like
it's just skin and you see like the
shape of a
of a leg but there's no muscle
definition or anything
and that the thing you don't think about
it's like you know when you like bump
into something
like i didn't realize that this the
muscle in your leg like
keeps you from like feeling that
basically you know you bump uh like the
chair
but on this leg it's like you feel it in
the bone oh you know you're like
a skeleton leg yeah it's like and then
they go it's going to take
when i finally started doing real pt
they're like it's going to take a year
for an orthopedic injury to fully
so like a year from now your left leg
should look like your right leg and i
was like damn
a year yeah i didn't know it was that
long i remember
i had a dumb injury i went out after a
monday night ravens game with a friend
out here we went to the park started
throwing the football around
and i step in a hole and i just wreck
i mean i turn my the top of my foot
touches the ground
and then i i get up and i'm like oh but
that's not enough
it it hurt so i keep going well then i
roll the other one
so i go home i just go to bed
i prop my foot up and i wake up in the
morning and this [ __ ] ankles like
this
i was like oh [ __ ] and i go to the
specialist and he's
dry like he's like yeah you tore
everything and he puts me in a cast
that holds my leg together i think it
was three months and it came up to my
knee
and it just basically he's like you just
need to [ __ ] leave this [ __ ] sit and
it'll
it'll grow back yeah but he's like
you're it's what he said to me you're
going to get fat and soft
i will never forget him saying it that
way fat and soft
and then when i took that k it stunk and
he took that
cause of old school yeah [ __ ] cast
and my
i already have skinny legs as it is that
calf was like nothing nothing man that
was like nothing that's another thing
that people would message me they're
like you're gonna get
so fat like everybody was messaging you
didn't get fat
i've lost 30 pounds yeah yeah but i mean
it really bothered me
that people were like you're gonna
really turn into a piece of [ __ ] now and
i was like what
and because you know who said the
opposite the pt
really yeah who's like been right about
everything she was like oh no you'll end
up in the best shape of your life
so i believed her yeah i was and i
remember saying it and and
seeing people they're like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about man and i was like
wait who am i supposed to listen to the
person who
therapists will write about everything
they're right about everything and i was
like
the yeah the the person that like deals
with this or like
some [ __ ] douchebag you know on
instagram right he's like
what but i remember i remember reading
that and being like
why would that happen they're like
because you're just gonna be a mess now
like i was like
okay but no she's been writing about
everything everything she actually said
she goes
she goes when you're like a like when
you're at a full year she goes i
guarantee
you'll probably be in the best shape or
close to the best shape of your life
and she was like and you'll probably be
stronger than you were
before you got injured that's great yeah
well you're already out there lifting
and everything else yeah i'm lifting
uh doing a lot of cardio yeah eating
right that's the only that's the other
thing i was not doing at all before
but i was working out a lot that like
that time
that's the thing that like also people
get wrong they're like well you
shouldn't just go from doing nothing
to that i'm like yeah but i wasn't like
i was working out like five days a week
i was
it wasn't eating great but i was active
you know yeah i was lifting i was
playing tennis
still even after we we competed i still
kept playing
kept training you know it's just [ __ ]
it's a freak injury man it's like a
freak [ __ ] yeah
yeah well i'm glad you were able to
capitalize on that [ __ ]
i got paid so much money
[Laughter]
let me ask you this you keep your
business to yourself but the money
you've made off the shows and everything
yeah if you knew going into it if you
break this and this
you'll make this would you go do it no
no definitely not
i mean i i look at it now as like you
know you can't
you don't want this injury or these
injuries now i'm
comfortable that they happened and i
feel like i feel like it has put me in a
better
on a better path like like i said with
exercise with diet with
like men so like i i see the positive
that comes from it i would never go like
hey man
if i give you this check will you take
these injuries like [ __ ] no
these injuries are terrible there's a
lot of people out there will take those
checks well it's so much money
i made so much money like like
it's it's alarming but it still is not
worth getting
that's injured yeah yeah well
uh thank you for coming on here and
doing this too yeah i love you i wanted
to have a beer here on our last
uh episode before you officially move
away but you guys are gonna be coming
back for a while won't you this will
make you laugh
i think so i have this we move out of
the house soon and then we're in a
hotel for a minute we visit family we
move into our house
in austin may 10th anyway i am back in
la
may 12th no yeah are you really yeah to
record stuff
do shows and record and then i come back
again
like three weeks later and then again
three weeks and each time it's for like
five days
so i mean i'll be here all the time now
all right but i love you i love you
you're the you're
absolutely the best you're i i think
back on like
you know it's kind of a new chapter to
like be moving obviously and like start
a life
in austin but you're definitely one of
the brightest
like memories that i'll have of los
angeles
no i mean like i i remember vividly
meeting you and being like attached to
you and
living basically living uh uh i invited
myself
to your apartment and i just stayed
there and it's the best memories i have
that's great so
we had a lot of good times man getting
emotional you know i love you dude no i
love you too and you know we'll be doing
well i'm coming to austin as you all get
settled i'm coming down to check it out
i want to come down
you absolutely have to check it out and
uh hopefully this uh
all this [ __ ] gets lifted and we'll
be we'll be doing gigs again too yeah i
can't wait for that i'm vaccinated i'm
ready to go god damn it let's roll man
i love you one more time promote
whatever you want uh just you know a
bunch of dates are coming
thomsongirl.com and of course we have
the the podcasts
so they're all on the your mom's house
uh
podcast youtube channel and i actually
have
ones that i started on my own channel
the tom cigarette channel yeah tom
tom talks which is so fun and then i
picked up the spanish one again
spanish one helps me because i'm touring
in spanish so i
i do that to like keep speaking spanish
because that's the one thing i realized
that
if you don't speak all the time it
really starts to fade on you yeah yeah
all right brother i love you ryan
sickler.com
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
channel
uh ryan sickler on all social media talk
to y'all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you